yep hello and welcome to this video will
playing jus rol turn yeah I could
accomplish mp5 for a change okay it's
usually interesting to play especially
com oh he doesn't yeah normally 96 they
goes especially cold but now not unhappy
with the neurology of course he an
actual is a good line I believe what
goes on with a five what's the deal they
are you apply a form and then go into a
five I guess then tie this one how I
play against that usually I'm quite
happy with such a situation here but I
one day and night 8 95 95 we should be
six very likely going to happen the
after night d 5 then I am probably maybe
still a little bit better with I'm not
sure about this
and I'm 95 there should be six something
hmm yeah something like that looks very
logical yeah not so clear what i should
do here relief can also play something
like that
[Music]
stupid unusual
why just this moon hey I'm really not
sure what to do here and then 935 look
all that bad huh I know he puts it to d7
interesting so in light c5 coming up
wall and that doesn't threaten all that
much what if I play for as 5pm just gain
space and the Santa repeat the 1s sighs
I also have east on it because he has
the night currently in a bit of a
precarious very finest we cannot take
okay not entirely sure
again that it can not be a bad porn
structure for four wide really what now
I would love to trade this bishop here I
wonder if f5 is actually possible him
his queen is extremely awfully on this
yeah this is working let's do it this is
looking I can make Bishop h6 afterwards
that's going to be very dangerous for
black I have 95 coming and his queen is
completely off side now this is strong a
leaf and threatening to take 2595 I'm
not threatening 25 immediately because
of 96 that that should defend yeah so
here I cannot go 95 because of the pin
at the moment so i have to take first
and then check on f1 is he threatening
something here was this nice move not
sure I mean look at one also looks like
a good move just trying to take them
I've got 94 Mary
I can take them doesn't matter
that we need to it's not not going to be
good so now I can check and I think yeah
I have at least a draw in hand but as I
think I should have more let's do it
let's check now you should h5 is
interesting check check I can also give
the check to angles to e7 time were
named Anita you know this is an a this
is a crucial moment I think ceasefire
could be strong let's go to c5 you
cannot take it I mean obviously I'm
stringing this up along as we go i
haven't seen all this provided it just
looked extremely dangerous with the
black screen stuck them and so on so the
tech is definitely a dangerous one I'm
just straightening out to take on d6
with the pong maybe I'll take that with
the pawn my time is not so great really
I wonder FES some tricks you on the
fifth-ranked after i take like ta group
takes Knight takes Knight f3 check-in
area some tricks main thing is I've
spent too much time but we know that
kind of thing that's nothing new I'm not
threatening night takes t6 unfortunately
because of the ok
[Music]
threaten screen h8 amongst others black
guys still have this bloody silent open
weird it's really weird but it still
gives me this this error message anyway
at the resignation is a bit I was a bit
surprised there is it really all that
lost and the engine confirms yeah and i
only had 44 seconds that made me a
little bit hesitant there yeah but it is
a win not that i saw at the forum group
g6 it looks very dangerous but the time
as mentioned this is an issue yeah so we
had this and here certainly on what is
the engineering rook cd1 after not being
not being very deep in the calculation
yeah i mean it should be strategically
fine anyway the d6 pawn doesn't look
good t5 is a good square and so on I
just looked extremely dangerous to me
okay the engine doesn't like it but this
is this is the kind of thing that it's
going to be dangerous Oh 94s of shooting
my idea ah of course hmm ok so then then
that was really it really bad I mean the
general idea i still like it but it
doesn't work yes I overlooked Maggie for
the problem is that here here I if I
take with the night my bishop is hanging
and and this is clearly not enough in an
ending yeah p an exchange down ah ok so
then when my idea did not work after
this probability look at least it should
be ok i am very certain so the engine
gives equal play with depth 20 and even
likes this motion takes
okay here okay King h8 yeah which is
probably a draw and this i can draw with
chicks very likely are there some kind
of Perpetual in stock frigate line that
is kind of its not very surprising and
then yeah Kendrick gives King age of
Wonders and their suspect that this
might be winning if it gets deeper it
what about c5 my new here that was not
so convincing the idea is not bad
probably this is working in okay that's
what he played right and now Queen takes
be true very cold-blooded I covers and
covers the night gather the engine
flyness is very very tough 96 check now
is the threat this this yes because pawn
takes root g6 Oh God okay takes takes
and now this is equal even though even
though I'm a piece up I have no check
here no single check that's that's crazy
line point xbox 360 losses look takes
rook t1j form 8-k technique so I cannot
take it with either at the end engine
gives this okay okay and this is the
draw yeah probably getting the perpetual
somehow I mean the night only eight is
really stranded so yeah he kind of fell
apart there through t6 it's difficult to
defend you White has son has press
the whole time converter yeah talk to
the hand but the whole the whole idea
didn't work here because Bishop h6 was a
blunder do 294 ok guys thanks so much